[Musik]
wir sind in den hamptons auf long island
dem ort in dem die new yorker nicht aus
klein gedachten müssen ihren
sommerurlaub verbringen
hierher verpflanzen sie ihre familien
während der heißen sommermonate die
miete bei den kleineren häusern startet
so ab 60.000 dollar für die dreimonatige
saison für die größeren direkter mehr
können es auch schon mal 500 1000 und
mehr seien durch ko wird aber habe sich
in dieser saison einiges geändert
erklärt uns die bürgermeisterin
wir hören viele gerüchte
doch eines steht fest viele leute
investieren den sec habe viele häuser
wechsel ihre besitzer
wir wissen dass viele planen auch dem
herbst über hier zu bleiben und unsere
schulen haben deutlich höhere
anmeldungen für diesen herbst
es kommen mehr leute ich finde das
großartig
[Musik]
genaue zahlen gibt es noch nicht aber es
in scharen an wohlhabenden new yorkern
die dieses jahr wegen krone in die
hamptons eingefallen sind wo sich das
leben so viel normaler anfühlt als in
der stadt in der das virus so gewütet
hat die nachfrage nach wohnungen und
häusern sei riesengroß selbst ladenhüter
die über viele jahre unverkäuflich waren
gingen oft für viele millionen jetzt weg
wie warme semmeln auf allen ebenen sei
der wohnungs und häusermarkt außer rand
und band egal ob kauf oder miete
erklären uns zwei makler ich habe so was
noch nie erlebt mietwohnungen bei denen
sich interessenten gegenseitig
überbieten
normalerweise machen vermieter ein
angebot und die mieter verhandeln 15
prozent discount raus doch dieses jahr
setzt der eigentümer einen preis fest
und kriegt dann fünf zehn oder 15
prozent mehr als die offizielle miete
einfach nur weil die konkurrenz so groß
ist ich habe noch nie gesehen dass
käufer so willig waren das zu bezahlen
was die verkäufer wollen
ich denke da gibt es verzweiflung die
leute sind einfach panisch mit dem was
da in new york ab
offen ist wir treffen robert payne papas
im april mitten in der pandemie ist er
mit seiner frau aus new york city
geflüchtet um sich in den hamptons
einzumieten er ist filmemacher sie
firmen anwältin in ihre wohnung auf der
upper east side wollen sie vorerst nicht
zurückkehren
new york das heißt menschen die sich auf
engem raum stapeln die auf der straße
voneinander abprallen all das ist jetzt
anders
ein großer unterschied zu früher ist wer
will denn nicht in einem new yorker bar
gehen ins theater in einem museum und
all diese dinge tun
all das hat sich verändert wenn das aber
alles wegfällt dann bleibt nicht mehr
viel als eine menge großer häuser sind
die letzten tage die sie in der stadt
verbringt sellin kaplan kam vor einer
ewigkeit aus paris um hier in new york
ihr glück zu finden
durch diese zeit geht für sie jetzt zu
ende fällt es dir schwer zu gehen
sehr das tut weh aber ich werde
zurückkommen
aber jetzt muss ich gehen es ist schwer
ich bin seit 30 jahren hier es ist sehr
emotional
der liebe wegen war sie gekommen
geblieben ist sie um sich ein leben
aufzubauen in dieser stadt der
unbegrenzten möglichkeiten eine
erfolgreiche pr agentur hat sie
gegründet
es ist eine großartige stadt mich meine
waren die energie war hoch du konntest
jeden tag menschen mit ganz
unterschiedlichen hintergründen treffen
abtauen downtown midtown vom künstler
bis zum banker die gegenseitige
befruchtung der unterschiedlichen
kulturen war faszinierend will ihn packt
ihre sachen geht zurück nach paris
die aufträge eingebrochen die
astronomischen summen für miete und
krankenkasse wie sie in kauf genommen
hat um hier zu leben aber bleiben
die aber kann sie sich kaum noch leisten
und wichtiger noch das new york dass sie
die so viele andere angelockt hat gibt
es nicht mehr
wenn du keine restaurants mehr hast
keine theater kein broadway keine oper
keine galerie dann kannst du besser
gleich ins meer gehen und die natur
genießen
warum soll man hier in einem appartement
eingesperrtsein und den ganzen tag so
calls machen
jetzt im august wir haben uns verabredet
mit christa moldovan und steve jobs
bereits zwei jahrzehnte haben sie zu den
top acts der großen broadway produktion
gezählt gespielt und gesungen in les
miserables kind gebuht phantom der oper
jetzt sind sie auf der suche nach etwas
neuem branche die gerade einstellen
möglicherweise im gesundheitswesen
amazon apps
ich denke an alle branchen die gerade
einstellen krankenschwester und packer
stadt große bühne in ihren job werden
sie auf lange zeit wohl nicht
zurückkehren können die broadway theater
sind geschlossen mindestens bis ende
januar wahrscheinlich sehr viel länger
manche produktionen haben schon ganz
aufgegeben
new yorks weltberühmte unterhaltungs
meile wird wie einst so reale
filmkulisse die straßen ausgestorben
gähnende beängstigende lehre viele bars
und restaurants sind pleite bislang gut
ein drittel in der ganzen stadt
niemand kommt zurück
das ist unheimlich es ist sehr
wahrscheinlich
all diese gebäude ohne menschen das ist
wie eine abwärtsspirale niemand in den
gebäuden keine touristen die theater
geschlossen
das macht angst macht mir sorgen wir
alle sind in diese stadt gezogen die wir
so sehr lieben um unsere träume zu
erfüllen um in der
unterhaltungsindustrie zu arbeiten
aber wenn du die miete nicht mehr
bezahlen kannst und keinen job mehr hast
dann gibt es wirklich keine noten
erhielt zu bleiben
aber nicht nur der broadway hat gerade
zu kämpfen
auch viele der großen galerien für die
new york so berühmt ist haben
dichtgemacht sind vorübergehend
geschlossen oder öffnen nur nach
persönlicher terminvereinbarung die pace
gallery eine der größten der welt wollte
eigentlich im märz neue
ausstellungsräume eröffnen
doch daraus wurde nichts die partie mir
die galerie mit voller wucht getroffen
jetzt hat sie wieder eröffnet in den
händen
gleich neben dem parkplatz der örtlichen
shopping mall in einem kleinen laden
hängen jetzt darf der internationalen
kunstszene
damien hirst preis morden erdrutsche
oder jasper johns magna gehört die high
end galerie die an die superreichen in
der ganzen welt verkauft warum hat er
hier in den händen zu eröffnet wollen
wir von ihm wissen
als ich im märz krank mit cupid im bett
lag kam eine frau zu mir und die frau
sagte alle fliehen in die hände es gab
ein gerücht dass alle brücken und tunnel
nach manhattan geschlossen werden
es war der reinste exodus aus der stadt
hierher ungefähr einen monat später
sagte sie
niemand geht zurück und ein neues
gebäude in new york city wird nicht
aufmachen
wir müssen hier draußen eine galerie
eröffnen ich fand das zunächst
vollkommen verrückt doch teure kunst
könne man überall verkaufen besonders
gute aber überall da wo die sind die sie
sich leisten können und viele von denen
seien eben dieses jahr in den händen
sie sind aus der stadt geflüchtet weil
sie es kunden und weil sich plötzlich
der anker der sie in new york gehalten
hat gelöst hat
die natur dieser pandemie hat den leuten
gezeigt dass sie außerhalb des betons
genauso effektiv funktionieren können
wie in ihm
400.000 menschen haben die stadt seit
märz schon verlassen sind weggezogen und
viele werden wohl noch folgen
new yorks büro hochhäuser sind im
schnitt nur noch zu zehn prozent belegt
die großen firmen haben bis auf weiteres
ins home office verlegt der markt für
büroimmobilien stemmt sich gegen den
kollaps der für luxusimmobilien ist
schon um 67 prozent eingebrochen
millionen touristen studenten und
pendler aus den vorstädten die jeden tag
die stadt geflutet haben kommen nicht
mehr ungeheure summen gehen der
wirtschaft new yorks jeden tag verloren
70 milliarden dollar hat allein der
tourismus im vergangenen jahr in die
kassen gespült geld das fehlt und das
spüren die in der stadt geblieben sind
[Musik]
unser geschäft ist um 75 prozent
eingebrochen
vor dem block bauen hatten wir viel zu
tun hatten nie zeit hier draußen zu
setzen
rund 1000 kunden pro monat hatte armin
vor der krise jetzt sind es nur noch gut
200 seine vier angestellten musste er
entlassen sein sohn hilft jetzt mit sie
würden nur noch für die knapp 7000
dollar ladenmiete arbeiten gleich
nebenan räumungsverkauf alles muss raus
auch hier keine kunden mehr
sierre robinson ist die letzte
angestellte geld verdient sie hier so
gut wie keins mehr
ich verdiene wir noch einen bruchteil im
vergleich zu dem was ich vorher verdient
habe um zu leben um mir keine sorgen
machen zu müssen woher ich meine nächste
mahlzeit bekommen
jetzt läuft auch noch ihr privater
mietvertrag aus und selbst mit dem
einkommen ihres partners können sie sich
zusammen keine neue wohnung leisten
im allerschlimmsten fall muss ich new
york verlassen
das ist das letzte was ich mir wünsche
ich habe so hart gearbeitet trainiere
tausende geschäfte pleite zerplatzte
träume hunderttausende arbeitslose
viele können ihre miete nicht mehr
bezahlen sie demonstrieren dafür die
mieten auszusetzen bis die krise vorbei
ist haben angst ihre wohnungen zu
verlieren 200.000 räumungsklagen waren
schon vor der pandemie anhängig fast
100.000 obdachlose leben schon jetzt in
der stadt new york drohe eine
katastrophe wenn der schutz vor
zwangsräumungen ende des jahres auslaufe
erklärt uns ern davidson anwältin bei
der regel aids society die mieter
vertritt noch haben wir ein verbot von
zwangsräumungen
doch wenn das ausläuft dann könnten
hunderttausende mieter ihre wohnungen
verlieren und obdachlos werden
das wäre ein nie dagewesenes desaster
für diese stadt
viele krisen hat diese stadt schon
überstanden aber diesmal fühle sich
alles anders an erzählt und selin es
komme einfach zu viel zusammen für sie
zeit zu gehen
dieses mal wird es länger dauern
wir haben einen dreifachen effekt es ist
als kämen die spanische grippe die schon
ein großes problem war und die
weltwirtschaftskrise von 1929 zusammen
und dann auch noch trump wie kann man
das aushalten was ist die hölle
new york steht vor enormen
herausforderungen
draußen in den hamptons aber warten die
die es sich leisten können die
entwicklung erst einmal ganz entspannt
ab